Mark Zuckerberg didn't have side hustles  if you do one thing and you do it right  and you do it all the way you can get as  big as you want a friend of mine has a  wife who's really popular she he runs  all their businesses and they have  literally 60 businesses he has an Excel  sheet to keep track of all the  businesses and I think they make about  total between everything maybe eight  figures a year we're having this long  conversation and I just said if there  were a magic wand and you could snap  your fingers and eliminate all  businesses but one how easy do you think  it'd be to grow that business he was  like oh my God it would be so easy to  grow that to like 30 or 50 million I was  like then why don't you do that and he  said that that question messed with him  for an entire year and he has since that  conversation shut down business after  business after business after business  so that you could focus on the one that  he thought was the biggest opportunity